true or false and why you don't brush
your hair cause I do live in once again
Durant single coverage shoots over
[Music]
everybody but with a lot of people okay
where's the song notice KD I'm gonna
take it there with tell the rooks I know
she had a lot a lot of deep questions
you want to ask me
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah it is you always heard the bad
things about the city and not so much
the great things that can happen in
every day I feel like I take a piece of
New York City on the way to work with me
so it's pretty cool well I know you love
you on this is one of your favorites we
love all the food here you love Zara now
I know you're here so much that Dhara
actually knows your or to memorize yes
what does he get with the price man and
we go back to almost what 10 years now
coming back and forth of New York City
you know so I got friends here already
and I live right around the corner so it
was easy where I met you when you were
an all-star in Orlando planned for the
Thunder we've been friends since then
what's the biggest difference between
the Kevin I met then and the Kevin you
are now it's a natural evolution of
being more comfortable with myself and I
just removed a lot of distractions that
I was putting on myself I guess what was
the hardest distraction to really
worrying about how he viewed after a
game how I feel after a loss instead of
just focusing on getting better as a
player every day I stopped investing too
much and like just the outcome of games
and more so just kept it at do it the
work that I put in I don't understand
this why on earth did every person think
you were going to the next I'm just a bi
anything can start again when aromas
happen and stuff starts and there's just
the nature of the beasts
there was Katie NYX billboards it was
like already graphics of Katie and Kyrie
aziah like in mixed uniforms every fan
on social media enjoy seeing what their
team is doing as far as free agency I
was at the Nets game against the Sun you
were pump fake and fake dribbling fake
shootin and I was like I know Kevin he
is itching to come back yeah the culture
of the game is definitely missing from
my life right now team aspect you know
watching film every day and just having
to go to meet as a basketball player I
definitely miss that so any times I get
to be on the floor and kind of do my
shadow moves I try to just trying to
envision what it'd be like when I get
back are you itching like are you ready
most definitely my body's gonna get
there eventually but mentally you know I
would love to play again for sure no I
don't think so or no no those are two
different no no the best thing for me is
the container rehab you're as strong as
I can and focus on next season okay I
want you to really paint this picture
for me you've been asked a couple of
times what you haven't really elaborated
yeah when you're back what is this med
team going to look like I have no clue
you I know you think about it yeah dude
head all you think about all the time is
basketball yeah so tell me when you're
thinking about the net squad like what's
in your head they're just different
lineups that we can play in use and with
guys that work well with each other
skills putting on a jersey and actually
representing Brooklyn on a road that's
it's gonna be an exciting time as well I
think this has become such a big part of
your story it's discussed so much your
time with the Warriors maybe the way
Golden State gives you it came up again
recently with John Moran Steph Curry
John Moran say something about Biggie
step folks to a photo of Iggy with his
trophy John Moran posted a photo of you
would your dopey what do you feel that
JAMA at once
plying my posting my photo no I mean
I've always been speculation about what
my place was on team what I meant to the
team I don't think they got anybody on
the Warriors like upset that he posted a
picture of me we're all brothers and we
won championships together
it wasn't anything more I guess just a
lord job I guess I think that the
narrative though that was on social
media separate from the Warriors was
like they got those two because Katie
was there its narratives they got
narratives for everything there's a lot
of stuff the casual fan don't get about
the game so he making a lot of
speculation on what they see isn't that
the whole picture
one thing you do say when this happens
you're like we're talking about
basketball in that life like yes I mean
because you hear all the trash-talking
games but it's like we're all the family
at the end of the day but we still could
be hard against each other but we still
want to protect each other whenever
we're off the floor and we all respect
what we do
I think the talk when you were deciding
what team you're going to go to after I
go to state was like do you feel like
you have to win a ring somewhere else to
solidify this idea that you can just win
a championship
Oh believe I can do anything that's life
by myself I never felt that we can win
championships based off of only what I
do I felt that way in OKC and we had
success in Golden State and we had
success in there's no hard to be the
same thing in Brooklyn are people seen
left a successful organization and
wonder why for the most part it's just
wanted to make a change in my career as
simple as that it's so crazy everybody
says really sometimes the business get
in the way and sometimes you know things
just don't happen but that one we did
have was special because you clearly
have these incredibly fond memories
about the teams but the way it's painted
is that it that isn't it yeah I mean I'm
just so open and honest about the
experience I want the message to always
be without those experiences I wouldn't
be close to Who I am today and they all
made me it still better than mine
they go Casey and gonna state and
hopefully I can take this into my next
experience and be even better I think
like a lot of players and really a lot
of people say you know I don't care what
people think I don't think most people
meaning no do you mean it yeah I feel
like I'm passionate about my art I'm her
Erykah Badu say that build a okay so I
play this segment with a lot of people
come on the show it is called true or
false and why the best NBA players come
from the Dean oh my god true okay why I
look at regions that uh when it comes to
basketball players these guys that build
a specific road I feel like the DMV is
making guys that get buckets what other
cities like do you put in there I know
it's accomplished um you push a car go
in there you know a lot of guys from
Chicago the staple of defense but it got
some good one-on-one players and good
bucket Gators out there in Chicago I
think I'll a is more so guys that can do
everything from pass score to
athleticism just saying so many
influences out on that side of the
country as well can definitely help but
your own kid form who he wants to be on
the floor so it I look at all that stuff
when it comes to looking at players and
what got me to this point as well true
or false and why you want to be a music
producer when you were tired boss I did
I did a few years back and not realizing
how tough it is to actually become great
I think right now I just got so much
respect before a lot of guys in that
position to say I'm just gonna do this
when I'm done you know so I think it's
harder than that yeah it's way harder
than that okay true or false and why
people take you too seriously to the
main topic around me the last few years
and that hit a lot of people hard so now
whenever I say something is getting
blown out of proportion and sometimes
I'm just like you could just ignore me
that's my whole thing is you can just
ignore me but I understand where it
comes from true or false and why you
don't brush your hair that is boss I do
brush my hair with me what people always
talk about on the basketball court I
don't care I come to the games actually
just grow out of bed yeah
and just go play I mean I'm gonna TV a
lot when I do these things so I see why
people make that but my whole thought
process is like I really just feelin on
the bed to go hoop and come right back
home some of the memes are funny
of course he is okay I got it laughs at
if I wasn't laughs at all that other
stuff they put on there yeah I was
afraid you got hurt there's this what
like three to four year stretch where
you could absolutely do you think it
could be argued yeah we argue for a lot
of guys well yeah for like I was in the
audience if you want to break into that
conversation you got to do some great
[ __ ] to leave you know you got it really
go out there and leave your mark and
leave your staffing on the game and I
want to be in those conversations I want
to play for a long time I have longevity
in the game or planning League you know
just because of what the guys before me
I laid out in the Jordans to Covey's
2kgs to the Tim Duncan
LeBron's even now I'm still getting
pushed by players in the league now
there's a James Harden's to the steps to
Gianna's guys are gonna be legends and
Hall of Famers when they done it's
pretty cool to know that I played with
some of the greatest players all the
time and they can and they respect my
game unquestionable greatness the
greatest
Kobe Bryant how did losing Kobe Bryant
affect you just can't stop thinking
about him and Kobe is somebody that I
competed against and it was a teammate
of as well I can go on and on about how
you made me feel as a person and as a
player and I just I love them always
gonna be in my heart always gonna think
about it when I go out there and play
and perfecting my craft and just try to
do right behind by being
the best person in Claire can be
everyday you know being on the team with
somebody and being their team that you
really see it for who they who they
really are to the core it's hard for me
think about you know cuz where she was I
wish she was still around
you said there were little moments with
Kobe that impacted you what are some of
those the first few practices in Team
USA and 2012
this is approach to practice and then
also how he played in the games and his
focus and what he wanted to do out there
on the court he was a defender for us
and a shot maker so I'd like to see Kobe
play a role outside of just being a main
scorer it showed me that anybody can you
know lock into a role and perfect it so
made me respect him even more for just
being a well-rounded little first player
as a Hooper I wanted his aesthetic as a
player it was pretty sweet to see his
methods and I didn't really get to
appreciate it until I got older as a
player and starting to see a hog that's
what he meant when he was doing it this
way that's how he felt when he played in
this game so you know I'm always gonna
live with codeme in my heart
[Applause]
question for you what player from the
90s would you most like to see in the
modern NBA sacra sure he would be the
most interest in the sea right now okay
why because he's so big and agile and
athletic that he can run and play in the
pace of space that we do now but you
could play small guys against them so
it'll be he'll be the ultimate like
Chico for the game okay so what's your
drink of choice I got a little 1942 in
here no not on the righteous for tea to
straight within the line okay and let's
talk some music you know that's another
one of your passion points what five
songs are in your rotation right now can
I take my phone of course when I listen
to the most right now mm-hmm
war about Drake you love that every day
is listen there at least three times a
day guess what
Russ Rick Ross that's a dope song you
got to take your ass out mouth Fabio for
Brooklyn so I got to represent that and
2 Chainz Virgil discount and I go jack
boys gang games a quiz yeah Don Todd try
this I'm really starting to follow
producers now who was some of your
favorite Boy Wonder 40 those two guys
are prior to got me into like one of the
follow producers you know
when I figure artisan Drake they produce
a lot and stuff bending into some new
cast that I heard actual beats Rico
Beach's guys a lot of guys following
Instagram that they post little snip
isn't a music that I enjoy
do you write music alright round
sometimes okay scrapbook full of wraps I
guess yeah
do you ever record it yeah I do really
yeah
and gimmicks to do yeah that's a huge
hobby is underrated how many guys had
their own in home studio as its
basketball players I go to some big
studio sometimes the most of times just
in the house creating stuff and have
people come over man JaVale McGee he's
huge like he has producers on tapes he
has huge artists on his mixtape as well
like every team I've been only had at
least one or two guys that in mind
getting into a studio so yeah pretty fun
I had DeMar DeRozan on the show last
season and he said he has a whole
mixtape it was her it except for like
Kyle Lowry Drake and Kendrick Lamar I'm
losing I want to say 2014 one of those
me and DeMarco in the studio in Vegas
no need the more Rudy Rudy Gaye rudy Gay
raps you know we all just play around in
there okay where's the song like where
where is it at
nobody's know putting no records out
we're just doing it for five I'm gonna
find those songs alright no problem I
don't know where I am but you know I
want - okay so you have a song with
damar Rudy I think you and LeBron have a
song yeah who else
well you're a mere Steven Jackson have
one a couple casick you know that I know
playing ball Mike come on go play who
was undrafted player coming into Lee a
few years back I mean I got songs in the
studio was just about not everybody but
what a lot of people okay have you had a
rap name what would it be probably easy
money
okay easy money you can ride with that
using money or slim Reaper or hard to
pick between those two Oh both okay
another top five question yeah you could
only watch basketball highlights of five
players for
ever who are the players
Kobe Mike I watched field
Shaq magic bran okay if I couldn't watch
it nobody else and they said I just had
to watch those five I think I could be
good the rest of my life my favorite
game that I play on the show it is
caught on this day you posted okay I got
a lot of post yes you do
May 2010 Twitter is better than going to
the club I was having a WAC night in the
club that night
nobody was dancing there I was just
staring at each other no like this is
where I come here for I guess I had it
up Tiffany when I have epiphany in my
mind sometimes I see so nice August 2009
I remember when I got attacked by a dog
walking to the bus stop I got on the bus
and I didn't have no lunch money I got
robbed by a dog to the bus by myself and
dog came out of nowhere
I'm reaching in my pocket when I got on
the bus I can't eat today I mustn't it
must have fell on my pocket last but not
least my personal favorite July 2011
bubble guts woke me up I had to check my
sheets for any slippage oh that's
embarrassing but I was really a comedian
at that point on Twitter or trying to be
and I thought it was funny
you ain't have no bubble guts oh if you
have a bubble guts ii-in life I mean
come on now the real question is did you
have any slippage yo can we cut that to
be on no need to take it there Taylor X
yeah all right Katie thank you so much
for coming on to the show go I got a
cheers to that
hey guys it's Taylor thank you so much
for watching my show take it there but
now that means you have to subscribe to
the YouTube channel you don't want to
miss all the fun stuff or the next
interview so hit that subscribe button
thanks so much see you soon